[Music]
i'm carrie mitchell i'm from the english
collective of prostitutes
uh thank you very much for inviting us
to this event today
we're going to start by watching a short
two and a half minute film
no you can't have sweets for dinner
because your teeth will fall out that's
why
we'll talk about it later
i really gotta go i love you too
bye yeah well thank you lord have you
heard anything from that client
no nothing no are you getting away night
class
really enjoying it yeah it's really good
it's good it's quite funny actually
because when ella comes home from school
she tells me about her day and then i
tell her about mine
what about you how's your mum she's much
better this week my sister's with her
and she's making a fuss around
she she loves that does she yes
we expecting anyone simone
because your teeth will fall out that's
why
i talk about it later i love you too
so
okay so that's the situation um
with the sex industry with the laws um
but just to tell you a little bit about
ourselves we're a network of sex workers
who work or have worked in different
areas of the sex industry both on the
street
and indoors and we can't campaign for
decriminalization
and safety we also provide um daily
support
to sex workers who come to us with our
you know with a wide range of issues
including fighting legal cases which
challenge um discrimination and
establish prostitute women's right
uh to protection against violence during
the pandemic
um because other sex worker
organizations have been doing a
fantastic job
of raising money for sex workers in need
we've been prioritizing pressing the
government to end
um criminalization um but
and also for a moratorium on raids and
arrests
um and for easily accessible benefits to
be made available
to sex workers because we're not
recognized
as workers most of us have not been able
to access those benefits
which um we should all be entitled to
and so thousands of us have uh you know
have faced
a terrible dilemma of either stopping
working
and not having any money to put food on
the table for our families
um or continuing working
um and making those same families and
the wider community vulnerable
um to you know us picking up the virus
um
so it's just a terrible dilemma um okay
so now
i'm going to describe um from the point
of view of sex workers
what would be the likely impact of
decriminalization of sex work
any proposal for a change in policy has
to encompass the experience of sex
workers
um policy and prostitution law that is
and here are some of the benefits of
decriminalization
drawing on the experience of women in
our network urgent action
is needed to address the obvious
injustices that sex workers face
to decriminalize prostitution
so decriminalization would increase
safety
ensuring that sex workers could work
together
and collectively organize and assert our
rights for better working conditions
police crackdowns break up safety
networks
women describe how they're running for
the police on the street and are forced
into isolated areas
where they're at greater risk of attack
and brothel keeping laws make it illegal
for two or more
um sex workers to work together as you
saw in the film
and that film really focuses on the
injustice
um and sex workers are forced
as i said to choose between keeping
ourselves safe and possible a rest
or avoiding a criminal record and
putting ourselves in danger
as these two women show um and for sex
workers this isn't a theoretical debate
um in 2013 um a woman
a young mother named mariana poper was
murdered
um in the wake of a draconian policing
operation which saw hundreds of women
arrested
and given prostitutes cautions all
around the country
two of britain's most senior police
chiefs at the time
acknowledged that operations to tackle
the trade are counterproductive and
likely to put women's lives at
risk but unfortunately little has
changed in that time
and a police crackdowns do continue um
including now during the pandemic which
is a complete
while it's always a complete outrage
worse still when sex workers report
violence we face prosecution ourselves
while little is done to go after our
attackers
and one woman who bravely contacted um
the police
when um after she was attacked in her
flat people came into her flat and she
was attacked there she was working with
others
but she did go forward to the police and
what she received from the police
was a letter saying that
any female at the address now who is
found at the same address in the future
is very likely to be arrested for
brothel keeping and that's because she
was working
with others for her safety she had no
choice but to move on
and she also later received a
deportation order she was a migrant
woman
she received a deportation order which
was only overturned
after a campaign that we spearheaded
and police resources are being
squandered raiding and arresting sex
workers
with migrant workers especially targeted
it was only after a four-month campaign
by our you know our organization that
charges were
eventually dropped in 2020 against two
brazilian women who were charged
with permitting premises to be used for
prostitution and they were merely
working together
for safety decriminalization of sex work
would also enhance health
research has found that the police using
possession of condoms
as evidence of prostitution makes it
harder for women to insist that clients
use condoms
it's also harder for us to access
appropriate health care
who can afford to tell their gp that
they're working in the sex industry
however on the grounds of health and
safety the royal college of nursing has
consistently voted by
over 90 percent of its membership in
favor of decriminalization of sex work
following decriminalization in new
zealand
sex workers have demanded that employers
provide better health and safety and in
fact the legislation
comes under health and safety as a
result of decriminalization there
more than 90 of sex workers
feel they have increased employment
rights occupational safety
health rights and legal rights
crucially decriminalization will make it
possible for sex workers to organize
collectively
to improve our working conditions not
only improve those working conditions
but get a pension
form and join trades unions
criminalization forces sex workers
underground where we are more likely to
be exploited as we have no legal
recourse
and in fact strippers have become to
unionize and in one case have one worker
status
decriminalization is urgent as thousands
more women particularly mothers
are relying on sex work to survive and
provide for our loved ones
austerity cuts in the previous
government
targeted women eighty percent of
austerity cuts targeted women and
mothers in particular
and government policies of benefit
sanctions and the unit and the
introduction of that terrible universal
credit have deliberately caused
destitution
everybody knows about that dreadful
benefit
decriminalization sex works would for
the first time
ensure some recognition of sex workers
contribution to the
survival of families and in some cases
whole communities
particularly in countries of the south
it is no accident that most sex workers
are mothers
mostly single mothers sex work provides
a higher wage
and the kind of flexibility you know
that's often absent
in other jobs horrifyingly some mothers
who've turned to sex work to make ends
meet have had their children removed
by social services taken into care
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you